les 150 citoyens tirés au sort pour
proposer des mesures de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique ont voté ce
week-end emmanuel macron avait décidé
d'organiser un exercice de démocratie
participative inédit en france après la
crise des gilet jaune est déclenchée par
l'annoncé d'une taxe carbone sur les
carburants
annie pata bonjour bonjour vous habitez
saint quentin en yvelines et vous étiez
parmi les 150 citoyens tirés au sort
pour trouver des solutions de manière à
réduire d'au moins 40% d'ici 2030 les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
comment avez vous vécu ces réunions vous
étiez dans le groupe produit les
travailler effectivement donc c'est
comme vous l'avez très bien dit cette
initiation venons de mouvements de vie
des citoyens de gilet jaune et qui a été
donc validé par le gouvernement a vu
donc naître la convention citoyenne qui
a débuté le 4 octobre 2019
c'est une expérience très riche et c'est
une fierté d'avoir pu à participer à la
convention citoyenne pour le krill a
vraiment et la finalité de toutes ces
réunions après ce week-end notamment ces
échanges c'est vote quel est le bilan
que vous dressez au lendemain de ces
échanges
le bilan donc vous l'avez dit lyon on a
travaillé en groupes thématiques il y
avait cinq groupes thématiques je fais
partie du groupe pro durée travaillée
il y avait également le groupe se loger
se nourrir
consommer et se déplacer sur la finalité
de la session 7 qui vient de se finir ce
week end
on a donc adopté les propositions de
mesures qui vont porter un consensus au
sein des 150 citoyens et pour la
majorité des propositions ont été votés
par ce large consensus en donc
maintenant à ses propositions au vont
aller dans les mains de l'exécutif et
des parlementaires sauf deux
propositions qu'on a demandé à soumettre
au référendum
parmi vos mesures dans votre rapport de
600 pages
la réduction
la vitesse sur autoroute de 130 km heure
à 110 km heure vous n'avez pas peur que
cela déclenche une polémique comme
précédemment avec la limitation des 80
km heure sur les routes secondaires
alors oui on l'a bien on a bien vu que
sa porte est justement débat dans
l'opinion publique
et c'était aussi l'objectif ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que notre lettre
demande à vous l'avez très bien rappelé
était de réduire d'au moins 40% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sachant qu'aujourd'hui la commission
européenne et même plus ambitieuse en
demandant 20 lié entre 55 à 65 % de
réduction il faut savoir que se déplacer
représente une très forte part de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
réduire de 130 à 110
on a travaillé avec les experts qu'on a
auditionné et ça c'est pas fait comme
cela réduit effectivement de manière
significative la réduction de nos gaz à
effet de serre donc quand on veut être
aussi dans cet objectif à des accords de
paris il faut aussi voir là où on peut
réduire réellement nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre une autre de vos
propositions adopté une loi créant le
crime déco side afin de sanctionner
nathan's graves à l'environnement
pourtant des propositions de loi pour
l'introduction de l'écocide dans le
droit pénal français ont été rejetés
cette année au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale
et qu'attendez vous alors c'est vrai
c'est principalement l'introduction des
limites planétaires aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne font pas consensus dans le milieu
juridique un ca et pourtant c'est c'est
nécessaire pour notre protection de la
biodiversité nos écosystèmes
alors ce qu'on a voulu à travers ces
propositions qui pratiquement une
proposition de loi c'est qu'on l'a fait
partir sur la voie référendaire donc on
le demande à ce que ça soit portée au
référendum pour que les français
puissent se saisir de cette question les
limites planétaire qu'est ce que c'est
que ce sont simplement des indicateurs
pour nous permettre de savoir à quel
niveau on a dépassé un certain seuil qui
nous permet de savoir si on est encore
dans une acceptabilité du respect de
notre biodiversité nos écosystèmes
donc il va falloir à travers ce
référendum on puisse nous communiquer
qu'on puisse avoir cette campagne
d'information auprès des français mais
sachez que c'est
vraiment un des thèmes qui est porté par
la convention et qui peut qui peut aller
loin si les français nous suivre quelle
peine souhaitez vous quelle peine un
conte terme de sanction oui en terme de
sanction alors dont la proposition il a
été demandé la création de ce qu'on
appelle une haute autorité comme une
commission à judiciaires injustement qui
va permettre de suivre à tout
toutes les demandes liées voilà au non
respect au non-respect de ces crimes
entre parenthèses négocier donc les
possibles c'est le crime lié à l'autre
écosystèmes biodiversité et la
convention citoyenne pour le climat a
réfuté une mesure à la réduction du
temps de travail à quatre jours par
semaine soit 28 heures hebdomadaires
cette mesure a été rejetée 65% par les
150 membres de la convention pourquoi
avoir rejeté cette mesure par rapport à
la crise sanitaire et donc à la crise
économique actuelle
alors oui on savait que ça ne faisait
pas consensus au sein des 150 citoyens
ils étaient tout de même important que
ce sujet soit ni à l'ordre du jour dans
le débat de la convention on ne pouvait
pas passer à côté
j'ai fait partie des citoyennes qui ont
défendu les 28 heures comme je l'aï dit
plusieurs économistes y croire et
propose même cette solution dans le
contexte de crise plusieurs pays même
européen a aujourd'hui propose également
c'est un ajustement du temps de travail
alors pourquoi les citoyens ont eu peur
ils se sont dit c'est pas le moment
par rapport au contexte ils se sont dit
ça va être mal accueillie par parler
français donc ils ont préféré à rejeter
sachant que la proposition était quand
même de donner une alternative jusqu'en
2030 ça veut dire que dans un horizon de
10 ans permettre cette cette mise en
place et ce n'était pas une obligation
est vraiment d'accord en accord avec les
branches d'entreprise les accords
d'entreprise permettent aux sociétés qui
le pouvaient et qui le souhaitait a de
pouvoir mettre en place ce dispositif
après l'aveu après tous ces échanges
quelle est la suite attendue
qu'espérez-vous
alors là on déjà ce soir on a de nouveau
rendez vous avec madame elisabeth porte
qui nous a rendu visite hier pour la
remise de notre rapport final donc ça va
être un premier échange pour justement
précisé un peu plus les ambitions et les
objectifs nous sommes invités à le
partner par le président à l'elysée dont
les 150 sont donc conviés à l'elysée
mais la suite de ça qu on vous l'avait
très bien compris nos propositions ont
comme issue 3,3 voit donc la voie
législative à la voie réglementaire ou
la voie référendaire
mais ce qu'on veut vraiment c'est qu'on
était 150 à travailler comme je le dis
souvent 150 visage et on veut vraiment
que à tous les citoyens français se
saisissent de ces propositions
que ce soit au niveau du gouvernement
n'est ce soit des organisations des ong
des militants mais des citoyens lambda
on me sollicite beaucoup en ce moment et
j'entends beaucoup d'initiatives qui
souhaitent intégrer le citoyen dans les
prises de décision dans la participation
délibérative et ça pour moi c'est une
victoire de la convention citoyenne et
comme vous l'avez dit pour rappel le
président de la république doit recevoir
les membres de la convention le 29 ans
pour apporter les premières réponses